من مصر والاردن سالنا الناس ما رايكم في
قانون يضبط نشر صور الاطفال على الانترنت
من قبل ابائهم
[موسيقى]
انا حره مثلا انا اذا ابني بنزل له الصور
افرض مثلا ان هو بيلعب لعبه معينه او كده
او حاجه هتفيد غيره او هو مثلا شاب مجتهد
في شيء معين ايه المشكله اما انزله طبعا
من حق كل الاب ان هو ينزل صور ابنه مدام
هتفيد غيره اللي عاوز ينشر يعني ينشر
اولاد الصور اولاده براحته ينشر واللي مش
عاوز مش عاوز لكن يعني بترجع للشخص نفسه
يعني لان الاطفال او الكبار او الصغيرين
ده حريه شخصيه للاسف يعني في اباء
بيستغلوا ابنائهم
فطبعا يا ريت يكون في حاجه زي كده طبعا
لحمايه الاطفال لازم الاباء يكونوا حراسه
جدا في الموضوع ده لان دوت طبعا زي ما قلت
لك بيسبب كارثه كارثه كبيره جدا
الاباء هم اكثر ناس خايفه على مصلحه
الاطفال فاكيد مش هيعملوا حاجه تضرهم ابدا
وهم لو شايفين ان النشر ده في مصلحتهم
اكيد هيعملوا لو مش في مصلحتهم اكيد مش
هيعملوها
[موسيقى]
اليوم هذا جزء من حمايه عامه للطفل اذا
كان الاهل بشكل عام يجهله الاثر السلبي
احيانا لنشر مثل هيك صور فاليوم لازم يكون
في اطار قانوني شويه يرجع الناس لصوابها
يعني انا مع هذا القانون الى حد ما يعني
حتى يحمي حقوق الطفل لانه كطفل صغير هو ما
بيستطيع انه يحمي نفسه او ما بيستطيع انه
يقرر هو ايش بده فاهله هم عم يقرروا عنه
او شو الطريقه المناسبه لحياته فالاهل هم
اللي بقرروا فهذا الطفل ممكن في المستقبل
ما يحب هذا الاشي او ما بده بالعكس هذا
قانون ممتاز يعني الا انه في ناس بتطلع
مثلا على تطبيقات تيك توك وهيك
فبعد مثلا اطفال تخويف الاطفال وهيك وفي
ظاهره كتير منتشره حاليا اللي هي انه
الاطفال بيمسكوهم بحطوهم وبيقعدوا عن طريق
انه تقريبا زي ما بدنا نحكي تسول عن طريق
الاطفال هم حاطينهم وبردوهم على السوشيال
ميديا قاعدين اللي بحط اطفاله وبشغل
القران وانه الاطفال وعشان الناس ياخذوا
يبعثوا لهم مصاري حزنهم اطفالهم فهذا انا
برايي اشي خطا جدا كذا مره يعني نشرت على
الوسائل التواصل انه ممنوع الاميات اللي
بتنزل صور ابنها وصور مش عارفه كثير غلط
هذا الموضوع يعني سيء انه حتى يعني ممكن
من العين ممكن انه ناس يستفزوك بصور
اولادك يعملوا تركيب صور ويصيروا لسرقات
للشغلات زي هيك